Donald Trump's recent attempt to pander
to black people has imploded in
endlessly hilarious fashion there's been
a bunch of talk on social media about a
white woman holding up a sign at Trump's
Florida rally seem like a campaign rally
that said blacks for Trump okay and we
have pictures of the individuals
involved here and there's this woman
standing behind Trump you can't exactly
see but most of the people holding these
blacks for Trump 2020 dot-com signs were
black people but there was this white
woman there as well okay and Trump even
mention them at the rally saying I love
the signs behind me blacks for Trump I
like the signs you watch you watch those
signs are great so clearly what happened
here is the Trump team thought hey
there's black people here who appear to
support Trump let's put them right on
stage so that they're visible on TV and
it'll help us in some way right maybe
will appear less racist or whatever
standard thing Democrats do this as well
Republicans do it your strategic in
selecting who's on stage behind you
during a rally all right also getting
buzz on social media was this guy that
in the picture there's a green arrow
pointing to the white woman with the
black spectrum 2020 com sign was with a
black man wearing a shirt that said
Trump and Republicans are not racist
gods - dot-com gods - dot-com redirects
to this man's personal website here's
the problem and here's the implosion the
entire blacks for Trump 2020 thing is
absolute and total unhinged insanity
that makes Alex Jones and Infowars seem
like pretty rational purveyors of news
and analysis if you go a few days ago if
you went to blacks for Trump 2020 calm
it would automatically redirect you to a
website called honest fact calm now you
don't get redirected automatically you
actually have to click a link that says
click below to enter so you go to
Black's for Trump 2020 dot-com and it
takes you to a website you hit a click
to enter button and it takes you to
honest fact calm
we have a picture of the website it's
absolute and utterly insane I mean
there's just no shortage of crazy stuff
it turns out that the man in question is
Michael Simonet he's a former member of
a violent black supremacist cult from
the 1980s called the nation of yahwah
which has been connected to extortion
and arson of 14 murders the group
allegedly required members to kill a
white person as part of their initiation
and after the nation of yahwah was
dissolved Simonet was charged with two
brutal murders in the 1990s one
involving stabbing a man in the eye with
a sharp stick he was never convicted and
he since accumulated four other felony
charges associated with this new it's
sort of a religious movement if you go
to honest fact calm it's filled with
religious quotes has not been convicted
he now goes by the name Michaels a black
man and has become an anti-gay preacher
and musician and we've got an image of
his YouTube channel he puts up long form
talks on YouTube some of these as you
can see here include tirades comparing
Hillary Clinton to the biblical [ __ ] of
Babylon believes that Hillary Clinton is
in the KKK believes Obama's the
Antichrist told the Miami New Times that
Obama's backing of child support would
be the end of three black men now here's
what's even more nuts Pat this wasn't
even the first time he was at a trump
rally he's been to multiple Trump
rallies invisibly so and Rick Santorum
actually had him open up a 2012 campaign
rally where he played completely
unlistenable jazz and went on a rant
about Democrats being Nazis
he's also praised Glenn Beck which quite
frankly in the grand scheme of things
doesn't seem like a big deal compared to
all this other stuff Wow can you imagine
a bigger implosion at what was really
broadly a weird event wasn't it yeah the
whole story just doesn't make any sense
to me I mean why is Donald Trump even
still holding campaign rallies you have
been in office for a month now and you
know the website named black for Trump
2020 you really have your eyes set on
2020 this early it's even too early for
Democrats to be discussing that you
couldn't possibly script something this
absurd and Trump's attempt to pander to
minorities explodes in its face
of course most people will never never
hear about this to begin with but
endlessly hilarious every step just so
boneheaded uh that even the pandering
implodes in such a funny and harebrained
way I have to admit I love it every when
I went to I I saw it and then I just
said well let's see what this is up
blacksburg trump 2020 dot-com boom I
mean just conspiratorial unhinged
lunatic nonsense promoted on stage at a
trump event yeah I mean you have to
wonder too how well these people were
vetted because if they're going to put
up signs that advertise for a website
yeah you wouldn't expect someone would
like the president United States I have
to deal with that sort of thing the
Secret Service should be on top of that
or you would think that somebody on
Trump's team would just say hey I've got
a smartphone let's go to Black's for
Trump 2020 calm and just see what it is
and maybe we pulled those people off of
the stage clearly didn't happen today's
episode of the David Pakman show is made
possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in - I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like an an
eyeglass or the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they started just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial com /t DPS